turning to climate disasters facing this
country president biden says hurricane
is destruction shows why we need to
rebuild infrastructure the president
highlighted the issue during the tour of
the flood damage in new york and new
jersey he said climate change is now
everybody's crisis nancy cortes is at
the white house with more on the
president's agenda nancy good morning
good morning to you nate welcome and yes
while the president was touring that
devastation he said it was evidence of a
quote code red moment when it comes to
climate change and he pushed for
billions of dollars in new funding that
he said would help protect americans
from the next disaster
thank god you're safe president biden
toured a new jersey neighborhood
littered with sofas tvs and toys the
remnants of hurricane ida dumped nearly
three months worth of rain on manville
in about five hours we're now living in
real time
what the country is going to look like
and if we don't do something we can't
turn it back very much but we can
prevent it from getting worse even in
the disaster zone he struggled to escape
the challenges dogging him back in d.c
protesters heckled him about the chaotic
u.s withdrawal from afghanistan that
issue plus a resurgence in covid cases
are dragging his approval ratings down
to just 44 percent in a new poll looking
to get back to firmer footing president
biden pressed congress yesterday for a
massive cash infusion
1.2 trillion dollars to make the
nation's infrastructure more resilient
and 3.5 trillion dollars on social
spending aimed in part at tackling some
of the root causes of climate change we
have to take some bold action now but
republicans argue the second package is
simply too pricey for a nation that just
spent trillions to tackle covid
we should maybe hit the pause button a
few moderate democrats like west
virginia's joe manchin are balking at
the price tag too joe at the end has
always been there he's always been with
me
i think we can work something out and i
look forward to speaking with her
but here's a wrinkle overnight axios
reported that mansion supports a package
that is less than half the size of the
one that the president is supporting 3.5
trillion dollars worth and so
what that means is that if the president
can't get mansion on board
his plan does not stand a great chance
of passage in a 50-50 senate tony
pretty big wrinkle there nancy thank you
very much